push push no no no turn really sure
around you break it shove it drink it
juice shove it shove it back
here we go don't bring the branches
dwight
ah i got a splinter well suck it up we
all have problems
hey everybody look what we have
[Applause]
nice huh i've got it leveraged
one one two two three
ah oh merry christmas
you driving carl no
abj i'm over my limit don't ask me
i'm going to sleep where i fall
doesn't that just epitomize the spirit
of christmas in the 80s
a gaggle of pie-eyed santa clauses
all trying to find a designated driver
to take the sleigh ride home
well i hate to leave but uh
i've got a busy night and a long haul
ahead of me
well hello ho ho everybody
and welcome to santa's toy land presents
toys and fun for children 1-91
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh uh please note that children 16 to 91
should not sit on santa's lap
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks mom oh god is something wrong
with the tree
no nothing wrong but it's almost nine it
should have been lighted up an hour ago
we waited for you
okay everybody count down five
four three two
[Applause]
one
[Applause]
[Music]
yes it is we are sending a message to
all of those who have forgotten the
scruples of
christmas cause in order to stay sane
you have to go crazy
i had a couple of drinks before the
meeting colette kenneth this is a flask
y'all probably shouldn't be listening to
me
isn't santa claus the greatest isn't he
the greatest man
in the whole world what else we got
i don't know this is for you
i don't know him very well this is for
you
well nobody really knows him because he
only comes around once a year
an easter bunny that's correct who's
ronnie millsap
i have no idea what's this
it's dreidel what does it do i don't
know
i don't mean to seem ungrateful but who
selected these toys
oh
all right get it out just just spit it
out
this is the worst christmas ever where
did you get all these stupid toys at the
dollar store
i hate you now kathy you don't mean that
i do too mean it i hate you to death
go back to the north pole and die look
who's here
ho ho ho ho hey hey hi so glad you made
it
what's up i thought you weren't gonna
come well it was on the way back i was
doing some skiing with a friend
here she comes hi merry christmas
we everyone everyone leanne hi
welcome come in let me take your coat
what is your life now
i don't know better
mama i wanted a cabbage patch doll with
long hair
how about you have no dog with no hair
oh thank you
okay chris this one is for you baby
is it a new album open it and find out
they were giving those away at the
doctor's office i'll deliver papers to
i thought you could use it for school
thanks i will
hey chris what'd you get
a calendar a calendar
yeah that's what i wanted see now look
here
did you know that mae what's high blood
pressure mom no
what if he had a calendar see all of
y'all should ask for calendars next year
that's a good idea
hey chris you want to go ride my bike
from the outside later by later
he meant summer yeah sure hey chris
you got this are you sure
yeah i'm sure all right holly here you
go
this is for you merry christmas carrie
you didn't need to get me anything
uh i think i did
oh my god oh my god it's gold earrings
oh my god
this is the best gift i've ever gotten
hope you like it
oh i do gosh i'm kind of embarrassed
about my gift to you though oh
please i'm sure whatever it is i'm sure
i'll be delighted
this is it yeah okay is it folded
a lot silly open it up okay
a mug yeah i painted it at color me mine
it's for your hot cocoa look it says
merry swiss mist i can see it i get it
that's great all right sweetheart our
turn to swap
here you go thank you
and here you go oh what a lovely box
i have a feeling my ship has
come in
you bought me the leather jackets
another old man cap
where's my cruise how'd you know about
the cruise
she told me he said he was gonna punch
himself
i can't believe this i get a stupid cap
and this stranger gets a pair of
beautiful gold earrings
hey i had to get her the gold earrings i
thought she was buying me a leather
jacket
plus i had to get doug as friggin
mentalo hey this is mental man
[Music]
hi santa is this mrs claus yes
she wouldn't stay at the north pole and
i told her i was coming to california
as soon as this party's over i'm taking
this slate at the beach
hey rudolph hey lisa want to play any
radio games
ah what the heck it's christmas
[Music]
she kissed me santa finally gave me what
i asked for
merry christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here you go
[Music]
hold up yes
it's what's inside that counts oh
you wrapped it come here kid
well there are lots of great treats this
time of year zucchini bread
fruit cake but the thing that i most
like to bring out at this time of the
year are my balls
balls
tell us about your balls pete
[Applause]
well over at seasons eatings we have
balls for every taste
popcorn balls cheese balls rum balls you
name it
for christmas and a happy new year
[Music]
for christmas and a happy new year we
wish you a merry christmas
we wish you a merry christmas we wish
you a merry christmas
[Music]
merry christmas merry christmas merry
[Applause]
christmas
[Music]
have you seen jake nope huh
oh dad you know what i don't want to use
those lights this year i i picked up
these just yesterday
peppers yes they're very fashionable the
chili peppers aren't christmas well for
that matter neither are scotch pines or
snow ornaments in the god sakes if you
want to be technical bethlehem was in
the desert
fine why don't we just decorate a palm
tree i don't need your sarcasm
but i always use those lights except
this is my house these are my
decorations just once can i have one
thing the way i want it this christmas
look wait a minute
i know you're upset about freddie but
don't take it out of here fine now
you're the psychiatrist oh i'd give up
go ahead decorate the thing don't use
your chili peppers oh i don't want them
anymore well i don't know
i'll go ahead use them you know maybe
we're gonna add a few radishes put a
nice broccoli on top
all right let's lighten this puppy up
well sean looks like another draw this
year huh yes
it
look at appears psyched golf balls
i also signed you up for lessons at the
uh golf pro down at the santa barbara
municipal course
sweet dad thank you all right your turn
oh all right
no idea what this is
what is this dear dad you got me
monogrammed psych golf balls and golf
lessons with the pro down at the
municipal
course i believe his name is pierre
booyah i got you old man that's it sean
you know this is the last year we're
gonna play this stupid little game oh
somebody doesn't like to lose because
you're an
old grinch during christmas time their
name's ebenezer
grinch man stop grinch of the cruise
scrooge grinch's sean
here you go here's your real gift what
yeah wait oh what's it gonna do let's
give her a rip
oh what's there what's what's in there
whoa whoa whoa
look at that that's me fishing
in the snow it's snowing that's really
nice sean that's great
thank you okay now if there's anybody
sitting here that does not believe
in santa i got to tell you you are wrong
i met him
a long time ago i saw him with my very
own
eyes and now if your grandfather who is
pretty old still believes in santa claus
i think he should too
and i was just a little kid and we used
to go visit my grandmother
and grandfather on christmas eve and we
didn't have a lot of money back then so
we had to take the bus
but anyway late one night christmas eve
was all turning into christmas morning
it was like 12 o'clock
very dark and we were getting on the bus
and i was taking the first step
and out of the corner of my eye i saw
something
a big red suit this long white beard and
had a sleigh with reindeer and did you
see rudolph
i saw rudolph and this big bag filled
with presents
i swear to god i saw him
and he winked at me he did yeah he did
[Music]
santa
is real and christmas
is magic christmas brings
miracles all right we're outnumbered and
unarmed if we're gonna get gina back we
need weapons this place sells hammers
wrenches do they sell plants because
some of that potting soil is very toxic
if ingested in large quantities so
you want to feed the bad guys a lot of
soil force
feed him okay that's a good option that
i will definitely consider
now let's go out there and gear our
asses up quietly
[Music]
[Music]
see the big black [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll teach you to have a dumb normal
name
all right where are you holding the
hostages i bet you'd like to know a
canadian no you're so clearly supposed
to be german
are any of you german russian mm-hmm
north korean greek i don't trust the way
the greek stands no one does
you there uh
yeah i was ooh but now i'm back eh meet
me in the service corridor we've got a
situation with the hostages
okey-dokey sorry to hear a boot that
service corridor that was great jake
thanks
so you guys stole her lawn ornaments
girl you are getting crazy
i told you guys i am a psycho
oh yeah you gotta let crayme out more
often
but call her something else cause that
name sucks
what's wrong with green hey man i'm
gonna i'm gonna crash
elsewhere tonight so not in like a
spiteful way or anything just
you know merry christmas
okay thanks
i can i can just like send you my my ad
the the address if we're gonna be there
i'll be fine yeah i'll just i'll just
drop a pin and text it to you then
okay well i think i finally figured out
these christmas lights
see if you can still call this fine wow
christmas lights i've never experienced
the miracle of little light bulbs in a
string before
[Music]
yeah super lame
[Music]
so
you